The wind and the sun high up in the sky there was wind and Sun both boasted that they were
stronger than the other powerful winds said look when I blow hard the trees and houses fly away every
everything on Earth can be destroyed in just minutes the warm sun spoke you can't say you're strong just
because you destroy everything like that what then what is strong you're just saying that because you can't make wind
wind and Sun continued to argue about who was Stronger right then a man was passing
by sun made a suggestion to Wind fine let's make a bet and see who can make that man take
off his coat what coat
ha what a joke it's just a coat I'll make him take it off wind sneered at Sun's suggestion and
blew on the man a cold wind blew where the man was walking oh it's so windy all of a
sudden my coat will go flying away the man
buttoned up his coat even more wind blew harder but the more and more he blew the man tightened up
his coat even more wind finally gave
up shall I try Sun began to shine on the man oh why is it so hot it
was so windy just a minute ago now it's so hot gee I can't stand it anymore I'll have to
take off my
coat the man took off his coat and walked on wind was surprised see blowing a strong wind isn't being
strong being strong is to be strong with your brains do you understand wind blushed at what the sun said